all right ted and we've got you covered
when it comes to the draft round two of
the draft actually started just a couple
of hours ago john treach is a part of
our coverage of course and john had one
of the coolest television moments of
this entire draft when he ran into
former college football buddies that he
has not seen in a decade just ran into
him and got an interview with them john
that was a special moment
it was amazing you meet so many
different kinds of people some you know
some you just meet and you become fast
friends and i tell you what we are at
the corner of flamingo and las vegas
boulevard but this is the intersection
of nfl nirvana father and son meeting
here for the draft the hicks family
we're in the larry zanka teaching your
son some history but as a sports fan you
retired in las vegas what's this
experience been like getting to see it
we came in just after
what happened in october one and
we were quickly became knights fans
raiders aviators aces
we've been i've coached for years and so
sports is
what we love we love the high school
sports college
professional it's been great all around
four years and
this is the peak right a year ago we
made the reservation come down here so
instead of staying at home and watching
we came down here got a got a room and
we planned a year ago to be here to
watch this and invited some good buddies
yeah and
we can relate uh
growing up as a dolphins fan you haven't
had a lot of good times you worked for
the organization but uh it's pretty
sweet to have hope here in las vegas
right yes that's the the name of the
draft is hope so we didn't have a pick
in the first round we got tyree kill so
that's our big hope this year but he has
the zonka jersey i have a dan marino
jersey because that's probably the last
time we were good of it but it's it's
it's been great we i got a buddy out
here with me visiting my parents we got
to run the 40-yard dash we actually ran
into dustin poirier on the strip this
morning and he made a pick for uh i
think it was the saints
so no the interactive part is cool
seeing the pics you know our friends
looking for us on tv we got ice cube
performing tonight and then after you
know you take a break from the strip or
the draft walk the strip and go back
it's it's awesome you can do just about
anything here and definitely enjoy
football reporting live john treach live
local now